THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
DR QUIRK NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. KNOWER K.
HAN BENNETT. BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HANEY HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA. HIGHLY
LACKEY LI LEVINE HELLO
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN SEG NAZARIAN WHEN-
DONNELL. PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH STONE IN BLIGHTED
AREAS VIA PULA VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS WILSON WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. I
REQUIREMENTS PRESIDENT THE
ASSEMBLY. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. DAZE PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN
THE NAME OF GOD THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. HOW
MANY GUN. IN OUR DIVERSITY MOLD
US INTO UNITED PEOPLE. EMPOWER
OUR LEADERS TODAY WITH THE
SPIRIT OF WISDOM. SO THAT
RIGHTEOUSNESS JUSTICE AND PEACE
MAY PREVAIL. MADE THE STATE
SERVE AS AN INSPIRING BEACON
WHOSE LIGHT WILL DISPEL THE
DARKNESS OF DESPAIR I MEAN. YES
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
STUFF. MEMBERS I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
STRONG THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. SOME HUMOR SACRAMENTO'S
ABLE NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY THE
SOMETHING THAT SEVEN AM
HONORABLE MAN MAIENSCHEIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOME SEVEN
DISTRICT RESIDING SHE FIFTY
PARKER THE DESK READING
COLLECTIVITY BONE READING PROCOL
FONG REPLACING THE MORNING ROLL
CALL SEVENTY THREE AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HIS RADIUS
MOVES AND MISTER SMITH SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMEDREAD AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. M. IS
RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER.
SB SEVEN FOUR SIX SKINNER FROM
THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER AB TWENTY
ELEVEN WEEKS FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY. MEMBERS WE
HAVE SPECIAL GUESTS VISITING US
TODAY JOINING US IN THE GALLERY
OUR GUESTS FROM THE GIDEON
HAUSNER JEWISH DAY SCHOOL FOURTH
GRADE CLASS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY.
ALSO JOINING US IN THE GALLERY
IS BRIDGET BETTING TEN MAYOR OF
HESPERIA RACHEL MOLINA HAS
SPERRY ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER IN
VICTORVILLE COUNCILMEMBER LISBON
SERRA ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH WELCOME THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY COMPETITION IN
FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX AND 331-636-1740. TWO
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
THREE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY NINETY ONE TWENTY NINE
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE OH
TWO TWENTY THIRTY THREE TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWENTY NINETY FIVE
TWENTY THREE OH ONE TWENTY THREE
OH SEVEN TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN TO TWENTY SEVEN FOR.
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE POINT
SIX POINT SIX TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY NINE
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY TWO OF THE
MEN SEVENTY FORTY THREE SEVENTY
FIFTY SEVEN. 1-322-044-2060
EIGHT TWENTY NINE SIX TWENTY ONE
ONE TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE FIFTY
FIVE TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN.
272-327-3720 SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT OH SEVEN TWENTY
NINE OF FOUR TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE TWENTY NINE FIFTY SIX
TWENTY NINE SIXTY ONE TWENTY OF
SIXTY THREE TWENTY NINE SEVEN
THREE AND SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY
TWO. ALL BILLS. BE DEEMED READ.
AND ALL AMENDMENTS. WILL BE
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE READ BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. WE HAVE ONE KING
CURRENTS ITEM. THIS IS FILE ITEM
MEMBERS. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE A. B. THIRTY FIVE. BY MS
REYES AND THE CLERK WILL READ. A
SINGLE THIRTY FIVE A SUMMARY IS
ANOTHER'S NECK LEADING TO CIVIL
DAMAGES ISRAEL'S YOU MAY OPEN.
MEMBERS TODAY IS HISTORIC. SOON
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A VOTE THAT
WILL SIGNAL AN END TO A NEARLY
FIVE DECADES OLD CONFLICT. I'M
SPEAKING ABOUT THE MEDICAL
INJURY COMPENSATION REFORM ACT
KNOWN TO ALL OF US AS MICRO.
TODAY WILL BE VOTING ON AB
THIRTY FIVE WHICH REPRESENTS A
RESOLUTION OF ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT ISSUES TO FACE
MULTIPLE GENERATIONS OF
LAWMAKERS IN THIS BUILDING. AB
THIRTY FIVE IS A COMPROMISE IT
WILL PROVIDE FAIR AND SENSIBLE
COMPENSATION TO PATIENTS WHO
HAVE SUFFERED A HEALTH CARE
INJURY OR DEATH. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME PROVIDING INTO
CONTINUED CERTAINTY AND
STABILITY FOR MEDICAL PROVIDERS
. THE BILL TAKES CARE OF
PATIENTS WHILE PROVIDING
PROTECTION FOR PHYSICIANS. AB
THIRTY FIVE IS AN EXAMPLE THAT
THE FIGHTS THAT APPEARED TO BIND
US FOR DECADES ARE ONLY AS
IMPOSSIBLE TO OVERCOME AS WE
ALLOW THEM TO BE. IN TRUTH I
HOPE THAT AB THIRTY FIVE BECOMES
A ODEL FOR US AS TO WHAT. HOW
WE CAN RESOLVE SOME OF OUR
FUTURE ISSUES. WHO'S THAT OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS REALLY WORKS
WHEN WE ALL GET TOGETHER AND TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S BEST FOR
THE COMMUNITY. AND THE COMMUNITY
HAS MANY STAKEHOLDERS AND WHEN
YOU GET ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER. AND REACH AN AGREEMENT
. WE KNOW THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
FAIR AND EQUITABLE. FINALLY I DO
WANT TO THANK THE BROAD
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS
REPRESENTING PATIENTS. DOCTORS
AND THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY FOR
FINDING THIS COMPROMISE I WANT
TO THANK THOSE WHO SUFFERED THE
HANDS OF. PHYSICIANS HOSPITALS
THANK THEIR FAMILIES FOR THEIR
BRAVERY IN COMING FORWARD AND
SHARING THEIR STORY THE LAND OF
FACE. TO THE TO THE ISSUE. VERY
SPECIFICALLY I THINK I WANT TO
NOTE. THAT WHEN YOU HAVE THE
ENTIRE. LIST OF STAKEHOLDERS
SITTING TOGETHER IN THE GALLERY
WHEN A MATTER IS GOING TO BE
HEARD. YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD
DECISION SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS REYES MEMBERS
A- BRIEF REMINDER PLEASE HIT THE
MICROPHONE BUTTON ON YOUR DESKS
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE RAISING A
MICROPHONE AND SEEKING
RECOGNITION I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE MR FLORA. YOUR
RECOGNIZE AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIVE AND I
THINK IT'S A- IT'S A GREAT DAY.
THAT'S A GREAT DAY TO GET THIS
DONE AND- THE MAJORITY LEADER
HANDED A LOT OF WORK. WHEN YOU.
THINK ABOUT AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR FIVE DECADES. AND
WHEN INDUSTRIES COME TOGETHER.
FIND A SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS ALL
OF US TO WORK TOGETHER. IT'S
EXCITING IS ACTUALLY WHAT MAKES
THIS. DEMOCRACY WORK. IS WHAT
MAKES IT FUN. WE DON'T SEE THIS
VERY OFTEN SIZE WAS A THANK YOU.
TO THE INDUSTRIES THAT WERE
INVOLVED. FOR COMING TO THE
TABLE. AND PUTTING TOGETHER A
QUALITY PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT I'M VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT
SOMETHING. THANK YOU MISTER
FLORA MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MATT MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF AB
THIRTY FIVE MICRO REFORM HAS
BEEN LONG DEBATED FOR YEARS AND
HAS FINALLY COME TO A COMPROMISE
THROUGH COHESIVE LEGISLATION. AB
THIRTY FIVE DOES TWO ESSENTIAL
THINGS IT EXTENDS THE LONG TERM
PREDICTABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
OF STATE LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE
IN CALIFORNIA AND IT PROVIDES
FAIR AND REASONABLE INCREASES TO
LIMITS ON NON ECONOMIC DAMAGES
FOR MEDICAL MALPRACTICE STARTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THIS IS
A MONUMENTAL AGREEMENT THAT ENDS
A DECADES LONG BATTLE FOUGHT
THROUGH EXPENSIVE BALLOT
MEASURES COURT ROOMS AND THEN
THE LEGISLATURE AB THIRTY FIVE
PUTS PATIENTS FIRST WHILE THE
PRIORITIZING BEFORE- ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. MEMBERS IT'S A RARE
OCCASION WHEN EVERYONE INVOLVED
HAS COME TO AN AGREEMENT AND I'M
PROUD TO BE A PART OF IT ALONG
WITH ALL THE OTHER. CO AUTHORS
AND THE AUTHOR THE PATIENTS
DOCTORS AND THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY I STRONGLY ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING AB THIRTY
FIVE BECOMING A PART OF HISTORY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I'M
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I JUST WANT TO OFFER SOME
BRIEF COMMENTS REGARDING IT. IT
IS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE DONE
LEGISLATIVE WORK CONTINUOUSLY
FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS MY WHOLE
FIELD HAS BEEN INSURANCE- WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU IS IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. THERE WERE TWO
PROMINENT TYPES OF LITIGATION
AFFECTED THE INSURANCE SECTOR
WHAT THE PROPERTY CASUALTY SIDE
ON ON THE- HEALTH INSURANCE SIDE
. MICHAEL WAS AN EFFORT TO CUT A
DEAL WITH. RACINE LITIGATION
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE SIDE HEALTH
INSURANCE. INDUSTRY TO STABILIZE
THE MARKET. RESERVE THE TYPE A
LAWSUIT ALSO COMING OF THAT TIME
THAT WAS NOT ADDRESSED. GOSH THE
SPAN OF A DECADE CERTAIN
INSURANCE COSTS INCREASED ALMOST
DOUBLE. VERY REMARKABLE. SO
THERE'S TWO THINGS HAPPEN THE
SEVENTIES ONE WAS ADDRESSED BY
THE MICROSCOPIC VICE. AND BUT
YOU SAW THIS EXAMPLE OF HOW
THINGS GO THROUGH THE ROOF IT
AFFECTS THE COST AND ACCESS WHAT
IS STRIKING. AND VERY IMPORTANT
ABOUT THIS BILL. IS IT RE OPENS
THE ABILITY TO PURSUE ISSUES OF
CONTESTED MEDICAL CARE. ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTED OPENS THE DOOR FOR
THAT SORT OF THING AT THE SAME
TIME IT PUT SOME BOUNDARIES ON
IT SO IT WILL NOT OVERWHELM THE
SYSTEM WITH COSTS SO THIS IS
REALLY A TREMENDOUS BREAKTHROUGH
. IT RE OPENS THE DOOR OF THE
COURTHOUSE FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
ACTIONS BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S
BALANCED IN A WAY TO PRESERVE
LONG TERM ACCES TO MEDICAL CARE
WHICH IS ONE OF OUR MOST
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGES- IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK THIS IS.
A VERY VERY STRIKING SOUND
INNOVATIVE RESPONSE. TO A
PROBLEM. THAT YOU HAD A BAD
SOLUTION WOULD ACTUALLY. HURT
LONG TERM ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE. I THINK IT IS A- AS I SAY
AN EXCELLENT BALANCED RESPONSE
INTERGIRO VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
COOLEY DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS SAYS THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO PRACTICED DENTISTRY
FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS. AND
STILL ACTUALLY CARRY MALPRACTICE
INSURANCE FOR THE WORK I DO- IN
FORENSIC CONSULTING THIS IS
HISTORIC- YOU NEED TO DO YOU DO
NEED TO REMEMBER AND REFLECT
BACK TO NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WHEN SKYROCKETING MALPRACTICE
PREMIUMS WERE THREATENING TO
DRIVE PROVIDERS OUT OF THE
STATE. AND THIS STABILIZE THAT-
AND UNFORTUNATELY SET UP A FORTY
SEVEN YEAR BATTLE- TO CHANGE IT
I THINK THE CHANGES ARE
APPROPRIATE I THINK THEY'RE FAIR
THEIR FAIR FOR PATIENCE I THINK
THEY'RE FAIR FOR PROVIDERS AND
ACTUARIAL STUDIES HAVE SHOWN I
BELIEVE. IN THE BACKGROUND THAT
THIS ISN'T REALLY GOING TO
AFFECT THE MALPRACTICE INSURANCE
A MARKET VERY MUCH WE'VE GOT
OTHER BATTLES WITH INSURANCE
RIGHT NOW THAT WE'RE WE'RE
STRUGGLING WITH FIRE- FIRE
INSURANCE IN PLACES HAS
SKYROCKETED- THOSE ARE OTHER
THINGS WE NEED TO MEET NEED TO
BE LOOKING OUT BECAUSE OF A
CRISIS. AND HOW WE RESPOND TO
THOSE- WILL- POTENTIALLY BE TIE
TACK. AS WE CONTINUE TO FORWARD
SO I'M I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS I THINK IT'S A
GREAT DEAL FOR CONSUMERS IT'S A
GREAT DEAL FOR A MEDICAL
PROVIDERS AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE. AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD. THANK WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. GOOD MORNING I RISE
THIS MORNING AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR BUT I ALSO RISE AS AN
OBGYN ONE OF THE MOST LITIGIOUS
MEDICAL FEELS THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT IF WE DIDN'T GET THIS RIGHT
THERE WAS A TRULY A CONCERN.
THAT W WOULD LOSE ACCESS
BECAUSE WE LOSE PHYSICIANS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. I ALSO RISE AS A
BLACK WOMAN. AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT THOSE WHO ARE BEEN WHO HAVE
BEEN MOST HARMED FOR MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE TO NOT BEING ABLE TO
BE COMPENSATED FAIRLY. HAVE BEEN
ARE NOT ARE MINORITIES AND ARE
FEMALES AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THOSE WHO CAME TO
THE TABLE. TO REALLY MAKE THIS
HISTORIC DEAL POSSIBLE. SO THAT
WE TRULY CAN PROVIDE THE BEST
CARE AND THE BEST ACCESS. FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOC WEBER. I SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
BIZRATE'S YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I THINK THE
WORDS THREE WORDS ARE
ACCESSIBILITY AFFORDABILITY. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR HERE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOT WHAT WE
GOT. THIS VOTE TODAY WE WILL
REMOVE THE DARK CLOUD THAT HAS
HUNG OVER THE CAPITAL FOR FAR
TOO LONG RELATED TO MID MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE REFORM. WITHOUT I
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
CONCURRENCE ITEM. AND WITH THAT
CLERK LEVEL ROLE. AS ADAM ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE WANT TO PASS RETAIN. ON FILE
ITEM. SIXTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR THROUGH
FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT. THE
ADAMA RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO SHALL BE CONTINUED. WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP. MISTER
JONES SAWYER IS MEASURE. AT THE
TOP OF THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. THIS IS. FILE ITEM
SIXTY THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND THE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY WILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE SUMMER
JONES SAWYER AND ACCORDING TO
JAILS MR JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S
WELFARE FUND CURRENTLY COUNTY'S
INMATE WELFARE FUNDS ARE
GENERATED BY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR LOVED ONES
TO THE PROFITS FROM COMMISSARY
SALES- I W. AFTERWARD REGIONALLY
REQUIRED TO BE USED SOLELY FOR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
INCARCERATION. HOWEVER IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE BILL
AMENDED THE STATUTE TO ALL SHARE
OF TO USE I. W. HAVES FOR JAIL
MAINTENANCE PERSONNEL SALARIES
AND BENEFITS AS A PARTNER
FINANCE WARNED IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE THIS IS THE FIRST
STEPS TOWARDS REDUCING FUNDS FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
REHABILITATION IN RECENT YEARS
THE MANAGEMENT THE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT OF GRAND JURY
INQUIRY SHOWING EVIDENCE I W.
UPS HAVE BEEN INAPPROPRIATELY.
UP UP UP PROVED FOR INSTANCE
REPORTS LAST MONTH FROM THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT USED TO FUND TO PAY
FOR TRIPS TO LAKE TAHOE RESORT
AND OTHER FLIGHTS AND LODGING
ASSOCIATED CONFERENCES WHEN THE
FUNDS ARE INCREASINGLY SPENT TO
BENEFIT PERSONNEL RATHER THAN
FOR THOSE WHO GENERATE THEM IS
CLEAR THE FUNDS ARE USED BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF ITS AMENDED
REGIONAL INTENT AT THE EXPENSE
OF INCARCERATED PERSONS OF
REHABILITATION AND REENTRY
FURTHER WE MUST REMAIN I W. F.
AS THE USE OF THE TERMS INMATES
IT BOTH OUTDATED. TO THOSE
EXPERTS. IN CONSISTENT WITH OUR
BELIEF THAT INCARCERATION DOES
NOT A PER MEMBERS ARE IS SK FOR
DR. THANK YOU JONES SAWYER.
SEEING MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS
NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
IF OUR FILE ITEMS EIGHTY NINE
THROUGH NINETY ONE. ARE ALSO
PASS AND RETAIN. WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
NINETY TWO. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR BY MR
COOLEY IN THE CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR BY
SUMMER COOLEY NOT GOING TO
INSURANCE MR COOLEY. GOOD
MORNING COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED
TO BRING AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
FOUR TO THE FLOOR THIS MORNING-
THIS BILL THIS BILL DEALS WITH A
VERY IMPORTANT BUT NARAL CORNER
OF THE LAW DEALING WITH
INSURANCE. THERE IS IN
CALIFORNIA SOMETHING CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION. AND I'M SURE ANYONE
WHO BUYS INSURANCE IF THEY IF
THEY HAVE A CLAIM. THEY WANT
INSURANCE COMPANY HAVE THE
ASSETS TO PAY THAT CLAIM. IT IS
ALWAYS A POSSIBILITY TO HAVE
ENSURE THAT FOR SOME REASON
ENCOUNTERS FINANCIAL DIFFICULTY
AND THE GUARANTEE FUND STEPS IN
AT THAT MOMENT TO MAKE SURE THE
CLAIM GETS PAID. OFF THIS BILL
WILL JUST THERE ARE. DIFFERENT
WAYS WE BACK UP TO GUARANTEE
FUNDING CALIFORNIA INVOLVED THE
ISSUANCE OF BONDS WE HAVE TO
STATUTES ONE DO WITH WORKERS
COMP ONE DEALING WITH NATURAL
DISASTER. THIS BILL SIMPLY
CONSOLIDATIONS TO PROVISIONS TO
REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE HEADACHE
IF THEY HAVE TO RESORT TO BONDS
TO MAKE SURE CLAIMS GET PAID THE
TIMELY MANNER. IT ALSO PROVIDES
SOME CLARIFICATION FOR HOW
SURCHARGE WHICH SUPPORT- TAMES
ARE HANDLED FOR NEW MEMBERS OF
C. GOT. AND THAT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU WANT
CARRIERS TO FEEL FREE TO SIGN
UP. AND IT'LL BE A FAIR PROGRAM
AND FINALLY IT INCLUDES- SOME.
INFORMATION EXTRA HOW CYBER
INSURANCE POLICIES THAT COVER
IT'S A GOOD BILL NO NO VOTES IT
STRENGTHENS OUR GUARANTEE FUND
SYSTEM AN URGENT AYE VOTE. AND.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY. MISTER
BIGELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF
MR COOLEY I ACTUALLY HAD THE
HONOR OF PRESENTING THIS BILL-FORM IN APPROPRIATIONS AND THERE
WAS SOME CONFUSION ON THE
RECOMMENDATION OF ONE OF THE
MAKE IT REALLY CLEAR THAT THERE
WAS A SUPPORT SUPPORT- ACTION ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND AS MR
AS THE AUTHOR HAS PRESENTED IT
IT WAS. A RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS A
STREAMLINING- ACTION THAT WAS
TAKING PLACE HERE AND WE- NOW
FIVE FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR BAYLOR.
SEE NO MORE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAMIS COOLEY MY CLOTHES
IF YOU WISH. REGION I VOTE
CIRCLE OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF OUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
DO HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP.
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE BY MISS
BONTA FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN. THE CLERK WILL READ
WITH AMENDMENTS. SEVERAL TWENTY
NINETY ONE OF THE MEMBERS BY
SUMMARILY BONTA MS BONTA ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS ON AB TWENTY NINETY
ONE I AM ADDING AN EMERGENCY
CLAUSE TO THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THERE IS NO
GAP IN PROTECTION FOR WOMEN IN
NEED OF CARE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
URGENCY CLAUSE IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE DRAFT JUSTICE A
LEGAL OPINION ALL BUT INDICATES
ROW V. WADE WILL BE OVERTURNED
SHOULD ROBY OVERTURNED WOMEN AND
BIRTHING PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ESPECIALLY IN STATES
LIKE TEXAS MISSISSIPPI AND
GEORGIA WILL BE STRIPPED OF
THEIR OWN POWER AND ABILITY TO
MAKE CHOICES. ABOUT WHEN AND IF
TO START THEIR OWN FAMILY. AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE INSURANCE OUT
OF STATE SUBPOENAS WHICH SEEK
INFORMATION RELATED TO A PATIENT
WHO RECEIVED REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
GRANTED BY DOING THIS CALIFORNIA
WIL PROTECT THE MEDICAL PRIVACY
OF THOSE PATIENTS WHO MAY BE
TARGETED BY HOSTILE LAWS IN
OTHER STATES. BECAUSE WE NEED TO
ACT NOW I REQUEST A RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR RIVAL. ON THE
URGENCY. THANK YOU RESPOND
MISTER FLORES. WE OPPOSE HIM AS
MINUTES IN THE URGE TO COST
PASTORAL CALL VOTE. MR FLOORS
REQUESTING A ROLL CALL VOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS FOLKS WHO WISH
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLE AND TALLIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
SIX KNOWS THIRTEEN THE MEMBERS
ARE TOP TO BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE.
MR KING HAS AMENDMENTS THIS IS
ITEM ONE OH SIX AB TWENTY SIX OH
SEVEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS. SEVERAL TWENTY SIX
OF SEVERAL OF THE MEMBERS BY
SOME EMERGING. MISTER KAY THANK
YOU MISS BAKER PRESENTING
AMENDMENTS FOR TWENTY SIX OH
SEVEN. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL AND CHANGE ONLY THE
PERSONAL DESCRIPTION THAT'S
WRITTEN BILL. WITHOUT RESPECT US
FOR ABOUT. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS UP PRINTED BACK ON
FILE. AND MISTER MAYES
AMENDMENTS AS WELL THIS IS ITEM
ONE FORTY FIVE. SB THREE NINETY
SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS. CINEMA THREE NINETY
SIX OF THE MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLY
REMAINS. MR MAYS ON THE MENACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER-
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
DOLLY IN THE LAST DECADE
CALIFORNIA SEEN SOME THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE IN UNMANAGEABLE
WILDFIRES IN HISTORY MANY OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN IGNITED DUE TO
HOW THEIR TREES COMING INTO
CONTACT WITH A LOGICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES HAVE IDENTIFIED
HUNDREDS OF HAZARD TREES
ANNUALLY THAT CANNOT BE ABATED.
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOCATED ON
PRIVATE OR PUBLIC PROPERTY WHERE
THE UTILITY CANNOT UTILIZE AN
EASEMENT OR PERMISSION FROM THE
LANDOWNER AT THE MEMBERS FEEL
FREE TO DO WHAT TO DO BEFORE YOU
TODAY AREBY WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND- COMMITTEE
STAFF OF RESPECT THE REQUEST AND
I VOTE. THANK YOU MISMAS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE DOTTED. BILLS OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I AM
REFERRING ITEM ONE FORTY FIVE SB
THREE NINETY SIX TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. BACK ON
FILE ORDER. WE ARE AT FIVE
NINETY THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
BY MISTER BENNETT AND THE CLERK
WILL READ. SEVERAL TWENTY ONE
SIXTY BY SOME EVENT AND
ACCORDING TO COASTAL RESOURCES
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FURTHER SAID
NATURAL RESOURCES SECRETARIES
CUTTING THE GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVE WHICH PROVIDES THAT
RESTORATION AND STEWARDSHIP
PROJECTS HAPPEN MORE EFFICIENTLY
AND COST EFFECTIVELY. AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY WOULD REDUCE THE COST
OF PROCESSING TIME FOR NGOS
SEEKING PERMITS FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS OR RESTORATION PROJECTS
BY ALLOWING CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO WAIVER REDUCE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT FEES.
ADDITIONALLY NOTHING IN THIS
BILL CHANGES THE LOCAL COASTAL
PLAN AS A STANDARD OF REVIEW SO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PRIORITIES AND
POLICIES CONTINUE TO BE
RESPECTED. WELL A FEW THOUSAND
DOLLARS MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A
SIGNIFICANT COST IT CAN BE A
BARRIER TO SMALL NONPROFITS WHO
OFTEN RELY ON INDIVIDUAL
DONATIONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR RIVALS. THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL.CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS NINETY FOUR. THROUGH. ONE OH FIVE PASS RETAIN WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE OF
SIX FILE ITEMS ONE OF SEVEN ONE
OH EIGHT ARE ALSO PASS RETAIN.
WE'RE GOING BACK TO MISTER
BENNETT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY TWO. AGAIN MR
BENNETT CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY BY SOME EVENT
AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO
ELECTIONS MISTER BENNETT YOU
MAKE AN OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWO TO STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE
THAT SEEKS TO SIMPLIFY OUR LOCAL
RECALL PROCESS THE BILL ALLOWS
VOTERS TO FOCUS SOLELY ON
WHETHER THEY AGREE WITH THE
STEWARDSHIP OF THE OFFICIAL
BEING RECALLED. AND IF THE
RECALL IS SUCCESSFUL THEN THE
SEAT IS FILLED ACCORDING TO LAW
THIS IS JUST GOOD GOVERNMENT
SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS VOTERS TO
PUT THEIR ATTENTION TOWARDS THE
DEFICIENCIES AND SUCCESSES OF
THOSE BEING RECALLED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS BETTER SEEING
NO MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
ON THE ITEM LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF THE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE TEN THROUGH ONE
TWELVE PASS RETAIN. IS FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. BY MR RAHMAN'S CORKERY
ASSIGNABLE SIXTEEN TWENTY BY
SOME AROMAS AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO ONLINE PLATFORMS
SARAMA FEMALE BUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FENTON
ON OPIOID OVERDOSES AND
POISONINGS HAVE BEEN A SCOURGE
IN ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS MANY OF
THE ITEMS ESPECIALLY WITH FENTON
ALL HAVE NO IDEA OF THE POTENCY
OF THE DRUGS. WHICH IS MANY
TIMES MORE POWERFUL THAN OTHER
OPIOIDS NATIONAL OVERDOSES ROSE
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN TO A STARTLING
AMOUNT OF 310-003-0030 FIVE
OVERDOSES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES REPORTED OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND OVERDOSES
CAUSED BY FAT NON TWENTY
SIXTEEN. WITH THE RATE
CONTINUING TO DOUBLE EACH YEAR.
IN MEETING FIRSTHAND WITH
PARENTS AND OF LOVE ONES WHO
SUCCUMB TO FATTEN ALL THE COMMON
THREAD AROSE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS AND THE ACCESS TO
THESE- FATTEN ALL DRUGS WAS
PREDOMINATELY EASY TO ATTAIN BY
THOSE IN THE HAVE FAMILY
HOUSEHOLDS. THESE PLATFORMS ARE
USED TO ADVERTISE IT MAKES IT
EASIER TO PURCHASE FENTON ALL
OVER THE INTERNET WHILE SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES HAVE INTRODUCED
NEW POLICIES TO ADDRESS DRUG
DISTRIBUTION THROUGH THEIR
PLATFORM THIS PRACTICE IS NOT
WIDELY USE. GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT ARISES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS THERE
SHOULD BE SOME REQUIREMENT FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO POST
THEIR POLICIES AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. REQUIRE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO POST POLICIES
REGARDING THEIR POLICY ON THE
USE OF THE PLATFORM TO SELL
ILLEGAL DRUGS AND DISTRIBUTE A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE A LINK TO THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS REPORTING
MECHANISM FOR ILLEGAL OR HARMFUL
CONTENT OR BEHAVIOR WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ADVOCATES
AS WELL AS A SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES ON CRAFTING THIS
LEGISLATION I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS TRIP. WE NEED IT
SITUATION. THANK YOU MISS
ROMMEL'S. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM CLICK LOCAL
ROLE. SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A NICE FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS ONE FOURTEEN
THROUGH ONE TWENTY ONE PASS AND
RETAIN BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY SEVEN BY MR LEVINE AND THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FORTY SEVEN BY SUMMER
GREEN AND ACCORDING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. MR LEVINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING THIS BILL ALLOWS
FOR THE ONLINE POSTING OF
SUPPLEMENTARY DOCUMENTS FOR
MEETINGS TO COMPLY WITH THE
BROWN ACT THERE WAS A COURT CASE
THAT RULED. THAT TIME IT COULD
NOT HAPPEN- PRIOR TO- OFFICES
BEING OPEN IN THIS BILL ALLOWS
IT TO OCCUR SO THAT. LOCAL
ELECTED COULD RECEIVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS ARE POWER POINT
PRESENTATIONS ONLY THE
SUPPLEMENTARY DOCUMENTS NOT
PRIMARY DOCUMENTS- WHEN THEY
BECOME AVAILABLE SO LONG AS THEY
ARE ALSO POSTED ONLINE. SO THE
PERSON COULD SEE THEM AT SO THE
PUBLIC CAN SEE THEM AND SO LONG
AS THEY ARE ALSO AVAILABLE THE
VERY NEXT BUSINESS DAY TO THE
PUBLIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MR LEVINE SENIOR
DISCUSSION ABATE ON THIS ITEM.
CLLR CORPORAL. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY THREE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ASCERTAINING FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN CORKERY. SUNIL SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN BY SUMMER C. OCTOBER IN
ACCORDING TO PRIVACY MR SAY ARE
TELL YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN IS A
CLARIFICATION BILL WHEN IT COMES
TO PUBLIC NOTIFICATION OF DATA
BREACHES. IN GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
IN A TIME WHERE PHISHING SCAMS
AND FAKE NOTIFICATION TO PREVAIL
AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
REFERENCES FOR THE PUBLIC TO
DOUBLE CHECK NOTICES TO ENSURE
AUTHENTICITY. AB SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN PROVIDES THE PUBLIC WITH
A MORE INFORMED UNDERSTANDING
CLARITY OF HOW THEIR INFORMATION
IS HANDLED AND ALLOW THEM TO
RESPOND ACCORDINGLY THE BILLHAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT ALL
COMMITTEES. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL RULES. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OF ICE FIFTY SIX NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS ONE TWENTY FIVE THROUGH
ONE THIRTY THREE. PASS AND
RETAIN. THIS BRINGS US TO MISTER
MCCARTY'S. FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
FOUR AB TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE SIXTEEN BY SOME ACCORDING
ACCORDING TO CONTRACTORS THIS
MCCARTY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THIS IS A BILL TO ADD MORE
CONSUMER- IN DETAILED
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE STATE
CONTRACTORS BOARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO- FRANKLY
LOOKING FOR AT RESPECTABLE
CONTRACTOR KNOW ABOUT AND ISSUES
WITH- PRIOR CONTRACTORS RELATED
TO DISCIPLINARY AT DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS- ASK YOUR ADULT. NO
OPPOSITION IN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CARTY SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLICK
LIBERALS. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
LETTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY FIVE AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
NINE. CLERK WILL READ. SOME OF
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN I'M
ASSUMING COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
AND ACCORDING TO TRAVEL SEXUAL
ASSAULT. MR STONE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. THIS IS THE COMMITTEE
BILL THAT CLEANS UP THE STATUTES
TO ENSURE THAT A SURVIVOR OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE.
PERPETRATED BY A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
DOES NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
PRESENTATION REQUIREMENT FOR
BOTH STATE AND- LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MICHELLE C.
NOTIFICATION DEBATE. CARCLUB
OTHER ALL. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM WHEN
THIRTY SIX THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY SEVEN AB TWENTY THIRTY
NINE. OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THIRTY NINE BY SUMMER
THREE OF US AND ACCORDING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS MYSTERY OF US.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THIRTY NINE A BILL THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN. TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY TO USE JOB ORDER
CONTRACTING AS A PROJECT
DELIVERY METHOD. THIS MEASURE
WOULD ALLOW FOR A MORE EFFICIENT
PROCUREMENT PROCESS TO ENABLE LA
METRO TO RAPIDLY AND EFFICIENTLY
ADDRESS SMALLER CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AT THEIR PROPERTIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS REGENCY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL OF
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. ROSARIO. THE CLERK
WELL CLOSE ROLE. TIED UP AS
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. ASCERTAINING FILE ITEMS
ONE THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH ONE
FORTY. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY ONE AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
AND THE COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY BY SOME
ARAMBULA AND ACCORDING TO
REDEVELOPMENT DOCTOR RANDY LEFT.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY WOULD
PROVIDE THE CITY OF SELMA A CITY
IN MY DISTRICT WITH ADDITIONAL
TOOLS TO FUND CONSTRUCTION OF
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU DR GRAHAM REALIZADO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CIRCLE OF THE
ROLE. SATURDAY ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM. MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY
THREE DOES TEND THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE OUT OF
ONE FORTY TWO THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY THREE AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY SIX NINE BY
SEPARATING IN ACCORDING TO STATE
PRISONS MISTER CHANG. THANK A
SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE GIVE THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
SYSTEMS. FIVE DAYS TO RELEASE
THE REPORT TO THE PUBLIC- THIS
DOES NOT DETER THE OFFICE OF THE
SPECTER JOURNAL FROM RELEASING
THE REPORTS SOONER- TO THE
GOVERNOR OR THE LEGISLATURE THE
BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HAS NO OPPOSITION. RESPECT FOR
US FROM THE- THANK YOU MISTY. C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
REYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE WILL MOVE TO THE
SECOND DAY. WILL MOVE TO THE
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR THERE
ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. BEFORE WE VOTE
WE WILL FIRST TAKE A FILE ITEMS
ONE SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVENTY SIX
AND ONE SEVENTY EIGHT ON CONSENT
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS. CLERK WILL READ
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
TEN BY SUMMER VIA THERE'S
RELATIVES MOTHERS DAY SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NUMBER 60%
OR NIELSEN AND OTHERS RELATED TO
ART THERAPYWEEK OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. SENATE
CHARACTERIZATION ATAPI CENTER
DOT ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO WHITE
CUT CALIFORNIA WINES DOWN TO
EARTH MONTH. CLICK ON THE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR ALL AUTHORS ON THE THREE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTIONS I CONSENT CLERK WILL
. CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED TO THOSE
RESOLUTIONS. WHO WOULD YOU VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF.
MEMBERS WE WILL BE PASSING AND
RETAINING ON FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
FIVE IRWIN. THIS ANY MEMBER WISH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
A CONSENT CALENDAR. A SINGLE
TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT BY
SUMMER COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
AND ACCORDING TO ATTORNEYS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SORRY ABOUT
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL TIED UP I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO. CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. CLARCOR RAD THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE OH FIVE. I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY TWENTY NINETY
SEVEN I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SEVEN
SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR WITH A
MISSING. I SIXTY TWO KNOWS HERE
ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
HERE ON THE MEASURE SOME PEOPLE
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR I SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SIXTY EIGHT BY SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO ASSEMBLY EIGHTEEN FIFTY
FIVE I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SUM
EVEN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIFTEEN I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
TWENTY NINE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
FORTY EIGHT I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SUM
ABLE TWENTY TWO SIXTEEN I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLE TWENTY
TO THIRTY SIX I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO SEVEN WILL TWENTY SIXTY
NINE I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SEVEN
WITH TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE I
SAID SHE TO KNOW ZERO ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY THREE EIGHTY. I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SUM OF TWENTY
FIVE ELEVEN I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SOME OF THE
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO SOME OF THE SEVEN
ELEVEN I SUGGEST YOU KNOW.
SOMEONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE OTHERS
MISSING I SUGGEST YOU KNOW ZERO
ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THE BILL SIMON TWENTY
NINETY NINE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY NINE
SIXTY I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SEVEN TWENTY NINE SIXTY SIX I
SINCE YOU TO KNOW ZERO HOUSE
RESOLUTION INTENT I SUGGEST YOU
KNOW ZERO SENATE CRACKERS IS
NUMBER SIXTEEN. I SAID SHE TO
KNOW ZERO SECRETARIES LISTENING
FIVE I SINCE TWO DOES ZERO SAN.
DIEGO I SIXTY TWO ZERO AND SEVEN
GROUP RESOLUTION. NINETY I SAID
SHE TO. ZERO
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE. OF A IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION. THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCER GERMANS IN MEMORY. ONE
CALL IS LIFTED WE ARE AT
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO THE
FOLLOWING MEMBER WHO IS GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR VOEPEL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IT IS WITH A HEAVY HEART
THAT I RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
AS OF A LIVES A BATH SMOTHERS
LIZABETH WAS THE FOUNDER OF THE
JULIAN PIE COMPANY IN JULIAN
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS BECOME A
STAPLE OF THESE COUNTY SAN DIEGO
IN FACT ALL PIES BAKED IN JULIAN
AND SOLD OR CALL JULIAN PIES.
SMOTHERS WAS BORN IN HUMBLE
KANSAS ON JULY TWENTIETH
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND LATER
ATTENDED HUMBOLDT HIGH SCHOOL
WHERE SHE MET THE LOVE OF HER
LIFE KEITH'S MOTHERS. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX AT THE AGE
OF FIFTY LIVES PURSUED HER DREAM
OF OWNING HER OWN BUSINESS IS A
BAKER AND ESTABLISH THE JULIAN
PIE COMPANY IN THE LITTLE TOWN
OF JULIAN CALIFORNIA. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE LIZ AND HER
HUSBAND KEITH PURCHASED AN APPLE
FARM WITH THE HELP OF HER SON
DAN. SEVENTEEN THOUSAND APPLE
TREES WERE PLANTED TO SUPPLY
FRESH APPLES FOR LIZ'S PIE SHOP.
ED SHOWS YOU WHAT BIG IDEAS SHE
HAD. WHILE THE ORCHARD OCCUPIED
MUCH OF HIS TIME LIZ'S
ENTERPRISE WAS IN THE KITCHEN.
ENSURING QUALITY CONTROL HER
GOAL WAS TO PRODUCE A PIE THAT
WOULD CAPTURE THE ESSENCE OF THE
SMALL MOUNTAIN TOWN OF JULIAN.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO ELIZABETH
IN THE JULIAN PIE COMPANY MET
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR THEIR
PIES BY EXPANDING TO AN
ADDITIONAL LOCATION IN SAN YEARS
A BILL. TODAY ELIZABETH PIES ARE
SHIPPED THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES WELL LIVES EVENTUALLY
HANDED OVER THE MOST OF THE
OPERATIONS TO OUR SON TIM SHE
STILL PARTICIPATED IN HER LOVE
OF PIE MAKING. UNTIL HER DEATH
LIZ CONTINUED TO OVERSEE QUALITY
CONTROL AND CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION AND IN ADDITION
SERVED AS A CONSULTANT IN A
PRIMARY RESOURCE FOR START UP
BUSINESSES BECAUSE SHE WAS
DEFINITELY AN EXPERT AT THAT LIZ
IS SURVIVED BY HER BROTHER. FIVE
CHILDREN EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN AND
ONE GREAT GRANDCHILD LIZ
POSSESSED A DEEP AND DROP AND NO
REAL SPIRIT SHE WAS PASSIONATE
OPTIMISTIC DEDICATED AND NOT
AFRAID OF RISK. SHE WILL BE
MISSED BEYOND MEASURE BY YOUR
FAMILY FRIENDS AND OUR WONDERFUL
TIGHT KNIT COMMUNITY MAY SHE
REST IN PEACE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. THANK YOU MR
VOEPEL. SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS. FRIDAY MAY THIRTEENTH
NO FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN
SESSION. MONDAY MAY SIXTEENTH OF
COURSE SESSION IS AT ONE PM ALL
ARE THE ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUE USING INTERNET FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MISTER MURATSUCHI MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON. SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
MAY SIXTEENTH AT ONE PM WE ARE
JERKED.
OKAY SO BOB. BOTH CHANGE FILE
ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING. BOTH
CHANGE THIS SUMMER THREE OF US
ASSEMBLY TWENTY SIX FORTY SEVEN
I TEND NOT VOTING. BUT CHANGE
MURATSUCHI ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO I TO NOT
VOTING. BOTH CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MURATSUCHI ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO HI TO NOT
VOTING.